aquí tenía su cruz y todo elevadas y ahí
estamos ahorita en la tumba desde y
bonifacio
está así como pueden ver un poco
descuidada y gracias a los vándalos de
aquí del voley del sector
rolando pinedo es descendiente de
bonifacio y nieto del actual rey de los
afrobolivianos su majestad julio pinedo
que vive en mururata en una zona
subtropical de bolivia su ancestro real
más antiguo según la historia es el
príncipe y chicho traído a las haciendas
de esta zona como esclavo desde senegal
durante la colonia los españoles que son
traídos para trabajar en la misma de
potosí y de ahí también unía los
patrones que ya estaban
mi alma
en los terrenos vacías y cada uno a su
patrón lo llamaba entonces ahí les
habían traído ya para trabajar a la
hacienda julio pinedo fue reconocido
como rey de los afrobolivianos en la
fiesta de la pascua de 1992 tiene 81
años y está casado hace 52 con angélica
larrea
pese a los reconocimientos son una
pareja sencilla de agricultores que
tiene una tienda de abarrotes sin que su
estatus implique un trato especial el
gestor cultural alejandro barra busca
que los jóvenes conozcan la historia
del pueblo que no sabe su historia y su
cultura es como una persona sin memoria
los afrodescendientes rondan los 35 mil
en todo el país pero su cuna estuvo en
estas tierras ancestrales de los yungas
donde comenzó la historia de la
monarquía afro boliviana